bien mesdames messieurs le président
sarkozy a toujours dit que vous seriez
invités à répondre aux questions qui
dérivent des travaux qui sont menés donc
cinq questions question vous est posée
cet après midi et vous pourrez y
répondre la première question
estimez-vous nécessaire de voter près de
100 milliards d'euros d'économie sur la
dépense publique dès l'été 2010 est afin
de rétablir les comptes publics et de
baisser simultanément la fiscalité des
ménages et des entreprises
vous aurez donc à vous prononcer pour
rétablir l'équilibré de l'assurance
chômage
êtes vous favorable au retour la
dégressivité des allocations chômage à
partir de 12 mois pour inciter à la
reprise d'un emploi
troisième question comprenez vous qu'il
soit proposé d'abaisser le taux de
remboursement de 76 à 73 % avant prise
en charge par les complémentaires santé
pour lutter contre le déficit de
l'assurance maladie
quatrième question dans le cadre d'une
convergence fiscale européenne
doit-on mettre un terme à la sueur
fiscalisation l'économie française en
proposant un contre choc fiscal de 25
milliards d'euros dès l'été 2010 est
cinquième question l'impôt de solidarité
sur la fortune exception fiscale en
europe
doit-il être supprimé pour faire revenir
les investisseurs partis à l'étranger et
dernière question
après cinq ans de matraquage fiscal 2010
est doit elle être l'occasion de
redonner aux ménages le fruit de leur
travail en diminuant 10 % l'impôt sur le
revenu c'est à vous de vous prononcer
merci